you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman leeches org
and I'm going to play a 15-10 game okay
opponent his fall through not our first
time playing I believe it's been all I
was expecting some bullet so just some
blitz games until now okay well this is
a bit unusual for white f4 and a quick
g3 hmm don't know if I've
conard this exact move order it's clear
where the bishops going okay
imagine the deep Han is going to commit
to d3 and white is going to aim for
acquiring an e for f4 duo that said I
want to probably stay away from Bishop
f5 I think there's too many a couple
different ways that Y could be and
gaining a tempo against the bishop I
think I know where the knight wants to
go f6 but I think I'm going to start
with this after all of that I'm going to
retain some flexibility with Michael
King Knight
about any pin here that would be super
surprising to see the bishop basically
faked me out g3 the bishop belongs on g2
so pawn duo knight on c6 and then maybe
we'll go from there I think I want to
put my bishop on the long diagonal
we'll see Wow oh man is that a mouse
slip
okay well I have to reassess things I am
much more inclined to play Bishop f5
this is now a hole and I know where I
want my king Knight I know where I want
my Bishop both pointing at e4
feels like this guy's going to struggle
some maybe White's going to go for a
double fee and keto okay so far just
three pawn moves for white to for me and
I think I just want to capture capture
Queen takes would be really weird
assistant so far there's a lot of
shocking moves here by white I'm being
honest
okay so maybe if I take Knight f3 is
gonna be played yeah
I'd probably be played takes Knight f3
knight c6 Knight takes pawn I couldn't I
couldn't sit on maybe putting more
pressure here alright let's start let's
start with this I'm expecting Knight f3
so they're probably going to
the Queen okay oh how I don't know
what's going on
okay development with tempo can't be
that bad
very simple mousses follow-up or and
I'll question the move order but night
here Bishop here pawn on e6 Bishop on c5
these are like the golden moves
he's six castle rook c8 Queen b6 this is
a half-dead pawn I don't know how it
gets in the ephors in
okay hard to argue with the placement of
these guys may be ready to gain a tempo
against the Queen so what's the bishop
going to do now that the Queen is here I
mean
time to support my poem so this kind of
pressure doesn't really bother me
the possibility to pin the night to the
Queen this might be lost for white
I didn't if
you put it on it on the computer I mean
I don't know it just feels like it's
already winning not saying I know how to
win it but then you know
missing
let's put the bishop here outside of the
pawn chain this is a hole
I really am thinking that d4 was a mouse
slip this is this is not really the way
to play capture Queen recaptures
development with tempo I could do this
now but I think the Queen wants to move
by herself like I don't think I need to
provoke that it just takes away squares
from the miners and let's get in e6
these Knights are offset
okay
maybe close to now okay
check
hmm and
I guess this move needs to be played
okay Bishop c5 check I guess here what
else
consider Queen b6 check Queen b6 Bishop
c5 94
I guess the queen is going to go back
here I may want to be prepared to meet
knight h4 with bishop here offering a
trade of bishops that would be desirable
um let's see I'm going to start with
this because then I have a at least the
move I know I'm going to have to make at
some point
I'm not going to Castle queenside so
I'll retain some options basically the
the final train of thought I had just
there was get in this check retain the
Queen's options the Queen is going to
have more possibilities than the King
the usual case of course so just to
check you know
continue to be surprised so night here
forces Queen here otherwise I get this
check-in and discoveries
for Queen here I think I'm also content
with just castling and no no rush here
has long term what is this bishop going
to do here's another thing if there's
some preparation for fiend keto I could
think about 94 and then clean up 6
hitting that rook that could be tricky
to defend c6 I could swipe the knight
and then pick up a pawn
I want to be greedy on castles Knight c3
I have 94 takes takes this is this is
nice whenever the knight moves the
bishops will be traded I see that
position as if the light square bishop
is already already exchanged and I have
the cozier home for my king
direct stuff that I'm missing here 94
pretty sure the Queen would have to go
here
II won I really don't see a great follow
up after that I'm still gonna just get
on with completing development
okay um
prepare to just continue to be surprised
we're only nine moves in but I've been
surprised for many moves now okay this
is dropping upon
I don't know what's going I really don't
know what's going on c2 is hanging if I
take here I have two unprotected bishops
Queen here picks the piece back up but I
could take the knight take the bishop
and then I could return here it is a
poem
Bishop takes pawn queen here Bishop
takes Knight rook takes how's this
bishop what's this Bishop going to do no
C pawn I mean I can maybe even get here
at some point ah it's just a pawn right
you're asking for a take back I don't
know how to
I want to treat this MP I don't think
I'm gonna give a take-back don't know
I'm confused by this take back offer to
it seems like an on purpose
and thrown my way immediately after the
move was played I don't know I'm gonna
say no to this so I think I'm just gonna
grab up on Queen c3 I have to then
take the night my first second I was
thinking of 94 no I dropped the bishop
so I'm forced into Bishop takes Knight
of Queen c3 so currently I'm going up
upon okay so 94
bishop could maybe be a little trapped
what about each six just a flight square
and then I'm ready to fly fly back to h7
I mean this is sensitive as well
I have to be on the lookout for is just
my clock if I do this night here with
tempo I do this he's kind of stuck I
don't I don't know I go with the flight
square trying to be productive with all
of my moves court grip K night there so
now at least for a moment my bishop
cannot be attacked this guy in situ okay
see one
hmm could also do this huh does his
white untangle
continue on the development train a
half-open file
just have to be a little bit cautious of
these these bishops could be well not
this one this one's under control with
this structure but this one here
concerns me some striking at the heart
however indirect it is the heart of my
structure g7 so I'm already kind of
getting ideas to b6 Bishop here Bishop
b2 Knight here oops
94 with Bishop f6 I want to just trade
I'd love to see a couple miners come off
95 I should be considering what about
different moves in my house I think I'd
want to put immediate pressure on it
then here here and I don't know that it
could be maintained as soon as this
night moves my bishops going here okay
and I think I will
just jump in let's get a quick move
kind of sidestep this with tempo okay
preparing before if I take here what's
uh what's gonna happen
nine takes and then try to get this in
suppose I do this first hmm okay b4 is
b4 is lined up I could just play here
stop there idea let's try that and stop
the one idea unless they were afraid of
a night jump in here but I don't really
want to budge I'm kind of I don't
if I should have done them and okay how
is how is why completing development on
the queenside if I play for clamping
down
you
I also have this mouth or even clean
here
let's get another
move in how is
sort out the queenside okay are up there
so really lining up this stuff I think I
want to
right now just to get this in hmm
yeah let's get that moving I guess the
big
go there but I want I want not a queen
of course okay my bishop see it this is
where I wanted this bishop for some time
now on g5 I have h5 there's no fancy g6
to try and break up my structure I do
have my bishop around defending
can even consider this and then here or
even blasting things open now
four takes takes hang on d4
now there's rook d1
have Queen b6 D Forte
Bishop takes Knight Queen takes I want
it I want to
change light square bishop
v6 prevent the smooth the development
Bishop d2 to see three maybe even offer
a queen exchange this this I should have
double-checked this idea I
make sure I could meet g5 with h5 I
don't want the G file to open up g v h5
think I should be all right if I get in
this chief
5 g 6 dark squares are weakened but I
have my bishop around that could secure
that so I feel like these pieces are
under control I just wanna you know
what's this Bishop's whereabouts going
to be would I really take this pawn if
Bishop there I think I will I am
guarding this so there's no you know
kink it might be pawn and return my
queen is you know hitting some stuff
bishops pinned my queen is around to
defend here should things open up on the
Kings side my queen is a defender
bishops a good defender h4 h4 eh
and then g5 forces the jihad open up its
many moves spot
I think the most direct thing to do is
somehow and get this in in a way where I
could have the light square Bishop 16 is
on my bishop after I do this I want to
be able to push takes and then play
knight here then a Knights going to be
exchanged light square Bishop is going
to be exchanged and then diagonals are
going to be you know that many more
diagonals
we'll be opened up towards the white
king this is a White's biggest think of
the game
Queen has some
of something like f5 I'd pick up a pond
okay backward move okay so I could get
this exchange in
let's let's take Queen takes I went upon
Fein cutout night okay
Ben now my queen would be excellent on
e4 I don't care about doubled pawns
doubled a pawns I don't care about yeah
and also with the time situation let's
get some faster moves in Queen on e4
this dominates the whole board I don't
know how you get rid of the Queen
besides exchanging Queen f3 I'd be ok
even with doubled epon so I'd still be
up upon and I have the better Bishop
that's the other thing so even if
somehow I drop upon my opponent has many
pawns on dark squares really this sticks
out these two and this one is tough to
move either illegal or just bad and so
these guys are potential targets to this
bishop
I was just thinking for a second that if
I uh if I make a mouse lip or something
I can't I can't ask for a take-back Oh
[Music]
like if I played b6 instead of
recapturing Anna hey six anyhow
[Music]
ran through my mind opposed to something
else right quick thought that ran
through yeah it's the mind alright so be
happy to have the Queen's come off so
let me consider something that would
annoy me maybe Queen f3 but
I'll go here of these two squares to
pivot on to get to e4
I'm leaning more towards d3 because it
would prevent development
this is actually a pretty interesting
square for a night
night a72 b5 so I like that I'll be able
to play a little bit faster and I do not
have any fear of my king now this is
earlier talk of g5 and the G file
opening up no issue
there's no attack against my king so now
I think my attention turns towards the
Queen side I'm looking at the bishop and
I see this as a a really good square so
that's why I was immediately drawn to a
knight on b5 it's stable and it fights
for the c3 square
am I missing anything fancy if I go here
and a rook is there and I play this
there is this and then I think they'd
lose control the file if they go in for
that stops so I'm gonna go for a
reposition of the night
right now our Knights
that we're here and here fighting for
these two dark squares in the center
have done some strange things 91 and a
fianchetto and now this one going here
not
in the keys 16 squares a couple pivots
by both nights outside this key area huh
now Bishop there I didn't consider
that's a that's a pretty nice move so
after it takes then this pawn is going
to be exposed I like that move real lot
well I'm thinking just doubling up now
huh
I can actually turn out to be a bit
problematic okay I don't have mmm let's
try what else can I consider here that's
a that's a very good move I was really
just focused on the c3 square
hmm okay
go here and here
this night is a long way off from the
relevant side of the board so that's
nice it's going to take him a couple
moves here here is probably one of the
better squares for the night so I'm
expecting this rook so the king could
start to pivot towards the Queen side so
let's see
brookey G 2 c1 I double and if this then
I think I have to go in for a capture
capture recapture and then this pawn is
going to be I think it's going to have
to run like this here well I don't let's
put this move on because I don't have
anything else to do I want my knight
different square I want my knight right
here also I think white has to go in for
this kind of this preparation to double
oh but you know what I have a cool move
if if this if this was gonna be the idea
to double up I was going to drop my
bishop back just to gain control over
the only open file yeah and well that's
what I have currently control over the
only open file so a knight here would do
a good job defending this pawn what does
the rook end up doing
if I get my rook here and I think I can
okay so the nice ready to put pressure
on this guy that's that's I see this is
time to get the King flying my rook is
good here hmm I can
fight against the night
just play here and have the night have
to work a little bit more I think I like
that idea actually yeah I'm also um
two-to-one majority in the center so if
this and then here maybe then I do this
try and be a giant pest to my pines
tonight just try and restrict it
entirely yeah I think I will do that
night here I go here I don't mind so
much about giving up this square because
I have my night around jump here jump
here jump here okay move my night
making one of these two
think I want I want to go for hmm here
here here here
wind stuff
here here here then there's that Oh
maybe night here I'm gonna go here
offend this pawn defend this square
would I really do this yeah I think I
will be my King on this square I'd be
better in this rook specific endgame if
the King tries to contribute you know
there's this stuff once my King is right
here defending everything under two
okay
King time thank you
King here it's okay I'm gonna try to
still be a giant past two that night I'm
opening up this square for the King I
also I'm opening up this square for my
night now there might even be some
mating nets
it's my rook gets active that King my
knight around I am I have I have it I
have squares to pivot with so now this
kind of pressure doesn't bother me I'll
be there in time so fiend keto here here
here to here
there's no good counter play for the
rook let's see what Y comes up with
you know I think this is these one of
these situations where I think it's
worthwhile to weaken this square in
order to try and control a white piece
significantly the weakness that is
created is remedied
so I see this
a strength so if I was
what would I do I'm not afraid of any
kind of pawn brakes maybe here maybe
this for this and then this I think I'd
go with rope d2 but
is still fight with this move now then
there's rook here rook here here and if
Knight see to I could take the pawn rook
d2
- Brooke b5 there'd be rook see - I'm
not there in time to stop this rook from
getting active evening out on the clock
so if worked d2 what would I do I think
rook d2 here night c2 here that move
Oh
well was my last movie for yeah the
night shut out I could go here and
defend this square from a different
angle I think I'm winning my night is
going to soon I think dominate the rook
even here here I could take on Poisson
yeah let me let me fight against let me
fight
against the idea white has behind the
last move also it's important I'm here
before the king could get to this square
there's a little little race I didn't
calculate but I I just I know so here
here here I'm there just in time to box
the king out
so I was
I can maybe be controlling the rook
night here and be three whether it's on
b3 or c6 still guards this square this
earlier idea I was thinking about with
rook d2 and night c2 won't be possible
with my night is on b3 so I'm really
trying to play against White's pieces is
this a move I don't think so how would I
here
just takes and you're giving up too much
material here takes here here here here
if white tries to maybe go after this
pawn I'm right be really fast and maybe
even take out this or this this guy's
just three steps away so is this guy
a couple obstacles in in the way but
these pawns fall this this guy flies and
we know who's not going to be around
anytime soon de to stop on I'm ahead on
the clock
I'm not sure what I would do is white I
probably just a king move you know get
these get these moves in you know King G
3 in here now up here if he
I take take and then do this okay
got this little Petrosian idea so if
here takes takes I just sleep these guys
sitting I think it's now it's time to do
something exciting with my night I could
uh where do I want to go probably here
no no no I love that night to jump in
here alright let's let's let's put the
night on b3 ooh I have night here which
Wow
night c1 I want to be care
bottom rook exchange okay we're taking
so here take stakes I don't like night
here to here I want to challenge the
king if I could get my king here I think
I just win this move I could maybe take
or here I go here you keep it closed if
I want I have that option so if I do
this I'm still controlling this square
preventing the B for advanced oh so here
check improve my King and then I could
return I think I'm gonna go for that
night on c1
let's put the knight on c1
now if the nightmare
this wonderful move with check-in the
key sixteen pressure on upon so white is
down to just a rook move now
eventually the Tempe run out over here
with the pawn moves and the King moves
and maybe I could even be a bit more
flexible with my rook it's no longer
needed to patrol the fifth-ranked so I
could pivot on c8 and maybe sneak over
on the h-file
I'm gonna keep it closed Brooke has to
go to the corner that's what white is
basically down to now here here bites
that okay so now now I get my king in
okay
ten he's pawn stars draw
right here I improve here I don't want
to allow the night to get here Oh
I just keep the rook a section off I
think I'm going to do this I want to
fight against this maneuver
I think the brook is gonna go for that
now yeah that move
I don't want the road
- active I don't want to get this I'm on
the night I take here I get two
connected passers down
time pretty sure they're busted but it's
still kind of tense it's always a relief
in these uh these standard games we have
the increment but it's tricky
okay
sure want to share with
I was surprised for a great portion of
it especially the beginning really
caught off guard
mmm I don't know I really I just somehow
think that that's a mostly but I guess
the take back would have been it at that
point if d4 was played and then there
was a take back I think I'd I'd uh I
allow the take back there this just
seems very awkward
of a stretch when I was saying well now
I I think it had given a computer game
from this position like this position
right here I think I think white is in
some serious trouble
white head white is better in the in the
center structurally has a square to work
with on e4 Queen's gonna have to move
again
what's the bishop going to do and the
moves are are too simple once once d5 is
in like that even even if maybe Knight
f3 was played I could see that as being
a different story I think that's what
the computer would suggest here just
fall
some basic stuff development with tempo
and I really got to share a lot during
this one so let's click on the computer
analysis at me I may take a little bit
so this is considered a I'm just a Dutch
or variation
you know an awkward an awkward start
okay and I'm a fan I'm a fan of this
it's you know it's a nice pandu oh I
can't get in a central one so I see in
deep on duo and it's already I mean look
at the evaluation I mean I took it's not
it's not considered best but it's it's
more there's so much more beyond just
being able to develop with tempo it's
it's this wonderful square that my
pieces make one move and immediately
eyeing up sod in the game how my Bishop
are you know my knight never jumped to
this square my my but my Bishop did and
then even even this idea with the Queen
somehow sneaking in to the e4 square
once the light square Bishop were
exchanged it's just a forever a forever
whole unless this guy's making a capture
but I have control over that
and this is this is a winning evaluation
put two computers add it what was it
saying Knight f6 Bishop out of five okay
both are fine let me let me click on
this again yeah okay it's already there
we have it
okay move move
I don't know after Queen takes d4 I
think yeah there maybe make a night move
Knight f3 instead C takes d4 and then
after Queen takes it's minus one point
four and it basically just goes that and
below from that um umm I don't know what
to really add with this one hmm yeah I'm
not sure this is where that take-back
request was offered yeah I kind of stand
by what I said with take-back offer
during the game just winning upon it's
not even considered best Queen b6
instead I know there's a there's a
golden moves you know if white is doing
nothing there's like this kind of setup
and I basically got to do
[Music]
moves in the game wasn't the exact
central structure but you get the idea
as far as the minor piece deployment
ten golden moves Queen here there's this
this is considered like a dream type of
setup and have all this in but the minor
pieces ended up position just like that
can't get in this move so easily but
yeah and I know that baffled with this
opening stage and just try and control
con control the activity of the pieces
you know I was sharing a lot of my
thoughts of of this clearly this is this
is the one thing I have to fear because
I have central control Queen side is
underdeveloped my king is this gonna be
a problem but I always kind of had this
under control it's prepared to play h5 I
could maybe even get away now that this
pawn is here and this Bishop isn't
controlling this square I do have
control over when I made that knight
move now I have three pieces on the g5
square so in order for the rook to even
be there supporting it there's these
under developing awkward moves that have
to be played and yeah when I have this
position I just see it that the
light-square bishop is already exchanged
in my mind the knight has to move at
some point the bishops are gone there's
no better diagonal than this one there's
no Queen Knight around anymore that
could challenge the bishop
and I think I'm a fan of I wanted to do
al-qaeda for this is this is even better
d4e for d3 Queen takes oh I'm on the
rook how much time did I spend on that
one that's where I went for the Queen
exchange
I was the reason I didn't play this I
considered it I don't know if I voiced
it I didn't like that there was this
move and I didn't have this square
available but I was totally forgetting
that I'm on the rook all right this
would have been much more direct we
wouldn't have gotten gone into this
technical endgame
okay yeah cuz if this diagonal opens up
there's no there's no safety for the
king the rooks will both be contributing
in the development for whites Queen side
remains backwards so f5 okay I'm just
doubling up yeah in if rook c2 I was
gonna play my Bishop back
okay there's even bishop here
maintaining pressure yeah why would I
have to go back Daffy also working with
the better bishops Oh
yeah back up like this if I take then
I'm allowing this kind of counter play
for the rook and you see the you see
things drop with the evaluation about
backing up like this would give me
control over the only open file yeah so
I'm just I'm faster here getting on the
C file that means there's going to be a
passive white rook in addition to the
material deficit from here just trying
to control the knight is this the best
move knight c6 I guess I could have
played King f8 as well was the - I was
trying to work out I saw I thought that
this was best 91 no e4 is best King e7
okay it's all it's all winning from
there 95 95 I have my pick so I guess
just maybe looking at the final position
and see how it could maybe carry out its
Knight c1 rook c1 that's something I
definitely wanted to stay away from okay
the computer could easily calculate that
I wanted to keep it mmm I don't
I wanted to keep the night just out of
play and I didn't like the the idea of
the night getting to d4 so oh it's night
there he's just kind of dead now f6 85
and oh as soon as I did this before
words played so if I just switch up the
move order mmm if I play rooks e2 this
was this is what I was afraid of rook c2
Roxy to Knight f4 I don't even one allow
the knight to be within us a jump like
within two steps away from getting to
this point so that's why I just fought
for the f4 square I think that does like
93 93 Brooksie to 93 and then that hits
don't want to open up the B file I
imagine I still could capture but it's
allowing unnecessary activity better to
just oh and also if this move I probably
wouldn't take I just go straight
infrared C - so b4 Trixie - and then
this is where white fell on on time so
if Knight here there's nothing and after
worried about this because the knight is
in the way and if the night is here
there's no there's no getting at these
pawns the knight is under control if he
goes in that direction and if he goes
here I could take and then I have two
connected passers and even if this rook
gets active these pawns are just way too
fast at this stage I could already bolt
with the e3 though I probably would go
with this when I don't like giving up
this square so I have my pick at this
stage would there have been anything
else Y could do
mmm it's not fun
a night exchange I'm Way too fast Rock
g2
and convenience the king and then go
somewhere oh yeah I could pick up these
pawns okay I have my pick at this point
okay well this is as far as it went
opponent and drop down time at this
stage but yeah okay as usual feel free
to leave any feedback to this video in
the comment section below I hope you
enjoyed it and maybe took a thing or two
away that's all for now take care bye
you